hello
ever since the election last October
there was a concern that this would
unfold supporters of the loser the
former president bolsonaro unwilling to
accept the results at Congress at the
Supreme Court and at the presidential
Palace thousands were moving in or
attempting to
from live streams online the early
moments of this seemed to unfold with
Little Resistance from the security
forces while tear gas was used but the
police were outnumbered the scenes have
drawn comparisons with America's recent
moment of democratic strain the January
6th protest in Washington
but here in Brazil there were no
politicians inside at the time
the election was in October the
far-right president ousted by his
far-left opponent Lula de Silva
the inauguration was last weekend
bolsonaro refused to go he's in Florida
instead president Lula was not in
Brasilia at the time but he was on the
airwaves swiftly
the policeman who participated in this
cannot go unpunished and they can't stay
in force they cannot be trusted by
Brazilian Society it's important for
these people to be punished in an
exemplary way
the security and Justice Minister
responded to developments calling it an
invasion and an absurd attempt to impose
protesters will by force
but the government here knows the
challenge Brazil's political
polarization is now playing out in the
heart of its political institutions
from abroad statements of support for
Lula and democracy were issued quickly
the British Ambassador we condemned the
violent scenes on institutions today in
Brasilia
we reaffirm our confidence in the
strength of Brazil's democracy and the
smooth functioning of its Democratic
process
and from the French President the will
of the Brazilian people and the
Democratic institutions must be
respected president Lula can count on
the unfailing support of France
this is ongoing in the coming hours will
be critical World watches Mark Stone Sky
News